politische wahnsinnig politische im die
diskussion um die frage wie beleuchten
wir jetzt das stadion falsche
entscheidung richtige entscheidung von
der uefa also ich denke die uefa hat
also ich hab das ding hat heute glaube
ich eine große wendung genommen insofern
weil alle das anders bewerten als ich
gestern noch bewertet haben alle gesagt
also das ist ein riesen fehler und und
habe auf die uefa sozusagen
eingedroschen und das hat aber dazu
geführt dass genau die aufmerksamkeit
dadurch entstanden es die es gebraucht
also eigentlich hat die ok so kann man
es auch trennten die elastische eigentor
geschossen
denn die ganze welt redet über diese und
über diesen vorfall und was besseres
kann in diesem fall gar nicht passieren
und ich glaube dass das dann tatsächlich
letztendlich dann noch die bessere
wirkung hat dennoch ist es in meinen
augen komplett scheinheilig also
gesundheitlich von seiten der mann von
der uefa sozusagen also nach dem motto
wir halten uns da raus wir erlauben das
nicht weil es ein politisches statement
ist in diesem fall
es ist vielleicht sportpolitik
voneinander zu trennen hat vielleicht
ein richtig machen guter ansatz in dem
sinne seien aber es ist trotzdem
politisch relevanter und daher kann man
es gar nicht trennen ich hab heute
severin den den präsidenten gelesen der
sinngemäß sagte das kann nicht sein dass
uns ein politiker sagt was wir zu tun
haben um damit einen anderen politiker
zu ärgern
das ist nicht unser job paten punkt es
gibt regularien da und es ist zu weit
passiert das im leben dass ein zweck so
wunderbar richtig scheint und dass man
das gefühl hat dass das heilig dann die
mittel nur das können wir glaube ich
nicht machen insofern da ich bin bei
jeder uefa wäscherei dabei weil die
haben so viele bewerber eine konferenz
league und einen nations league findet
der die alle kritik dieser welt sie
haben diese diese
kolorierung des stadions nicht verboten
weil sie für rassismus führt für
homophobie und und nimmt sondern sie
haben sind ihren regularien gefolgt es
wenn dieses stadion von vom ersten tag
an in diesen farben gewesen wäre dann
hätte ich mir dann würde ich hier für
die bücher jetzt verbietet ihr es gegen
ungarn gegner das schaue ich mir an jung
da ist richtig was los
es war nicht gut geht es war gut gemeint
aber es war am ende gut durchgezogen und
ein bisschen rechtssicherheit musst du
haben wenn wenn wenn es einmal gilt wir
machen solche aktionen bitte nicht weil
das bei uns in den in den regularien
steht und wo jetzt das treibt jetzt
wieder auf jault wie gesagt der zweck
wunderbar aber ich glaube sie konnten
gar nicht anders handeln und ja am ende
ist es für alle beteiligten
du bist jetzt herausgekommen ist so viel
das wird überall auf machen den
nachrichten ich weiß nicht ob es der
aufmacher gewesen wäre wenn der stadion
ganz entspannt in den farben hat jeder
wäre also das was in ungarn passiert ist
wird es tut nicht lösen können einfach
nur über das stadion zu kolorieren oder
dem muss sich auch die die eu auch
politisch dann belastet so auf den sport
um fußball geht weiter hat sich frau von
der leyen endlich mal hingestellt gesagt
das was da abgestimmte uhr dem im
parlament in budapest ist eine schande
so wie jetzt hätte ich gerne mal ein
bisschen sanktion ja aus der politik
raus aber haben wir haben wir gestern
darüber gesprochen ich meine ursula von
der leyen ist ganz maßgeblich mit hilfe
ungarn in dieses amt gekommen
ja und der bayerische ministerpräsident
begrüßte norbert auch so waren wir
gestern des öfteren bei der csu und aber
jetzt sollte das stadion bitte in den
regenbogenfarben
dann zeigen wir dem abermals das war ein
bisschen wie gesagt gut gedacht und gut
gewollt möglicherweise aber ich finde
ich man hätte es machen sollen dürfen
denn es kann nie falsch sein ein
positives signal auszusenden es kann
nicht wahr sein egal ob es in dem moment
wie im umgang
es kann es geht mir geht hier nicht um
politik und ich glaube das darf ich
nicht um politik es geht um
menschenrechte und das ist für mich
wieder was bringe ich meine kinder bei
das ist so was ich liebe dich zu sagen
guck mal schwarz deswegen und für mich
ist es eine sache ist wir sehen ja bei
dieser em wunderbar dass jeder mit
corona umgeht so wie es ihm passt die
einen machen die starken voll
die anderen sagen viertel der auslastung
mit abstand die anderen sagen ein
viertel der auslastung aber die können
dann doch ein bisschen nah beieinander
bin mit vielerlei es gibt in china gas
und wo nicht mit mars gewissen seiten
gemessen sein darf bis bei ein thema wie
menschenrechte und liebe und wenn man
man frau frau frau mann völlig egal
und deswegen ist für mich so ein signal
muss immer erlaubt sein immer und das
ist für mich nicht politisch das ist da
ist darf nicht verboten seien gute dinge
auszustrahlen das ist ja wenn es eine
mannschaft mit dem trikot mit einem
herzen auflaufen will dann ist es ein
schönes signal dass solche fiel hessen
auflaufen von mir aus weil das was
schönes ist und nicht mit totenkopf und
das ist für mich falsch zu sagen ja
einem falschen zeitpunkt jetzt nein für
mich gibt für gute dinge nie den
falschen zeitpunkt das klingt alles sehr
schön und würde auch jeder sofort
unterschreiben wir sollten dem
widersprechen
auf der anderen seite ewald lienen wir
sind jetzt ich sage nicht weh tun wir
sind sehr tolerant
manchmal tun so als wären wir sehr
tolerant fragen wie wenn wir wirklich so
tolerant sind warum outen sich denn da
nicht schwule fußballer auch in der
deutschen bundesliga beispielsweise
warum warum man das thema gibt's da gibt
es ein adoptionsrecht für homosexuelle
nein also ich wissen was ich meine
also dann decken wir jetzt plötzlich in
der konfrontation im konflikt mit
ordnern entdeckten wir plötzlich na ja
wir haben die menschenrechte s6
regenbogen in soja und so weiter das
hashtag politik gestern war das ein
wunderbares beispiel mit
wie der hans tobias ranzinger der
minister gesagt hat und und man sich
fragen muss ja im moment warum steht da
nicht im programm ein adoptionsrecht das
hat ja erklärt er sagte es gab kein
platz 39 seiten oder wer hat ja auch
gesagt wenn ich ich bin eine volkspartei
und ich muss so viele menschen wie
möglich erreichen und dabei kann man
natürlich auch niemandem wehtun und
sonst wählen mich die leute nicht also
es ist völlig klar dass nur zeichen das
was du gesagt hast auch nur zeichen zu
setzen reicht natürlich nicht aus es
muss gelebt werden
ich muss die dinge umsetzen aber ich bin
natürlich in diesem fall 1000
tatsächlich bei giovanni s es geht nicht
ich mache politik mit videos aufnehmen
es geht um menschenrechte und die großen
sport organisation fifa uefa selbst die
die einzelnen sportfachverbände die alle
olympische sportarten betreiben haben
haben die politik erfunden die
vermischung zwischen großereignissen und
und politik erfunden gesehen ist
zugelassen es fällt doch auch auf an
welche länder mittlerweile solche
großereignisse vergeben wir seit
jahrzehnten verlassen das ist jetzt
nicht die speerspitze der länder die so
normal für die einhaltung von
menschenrechten steht nicht euch alle um
himmels willen aber die kandidaten ganz
wichtiges argument es geht doch hier
gern schlecht und ergreifend um geld und
das ist nämlich genau mit münchen
passiert ist dass der oberbürgermeister
bei der uefa anfragen musste hat
folgenden hintergrund weil sie an ein
bestimmtes vertragswerk gehalten weil
sie sich verkauft haben quasi ihr saß
verkauft haben für dieses großereignis
und tod und leben in dem moment wo das
ist wohl das geld fließt kannst du da
nicht hingehen und sagen so nach dem
motto biallo ich das mal im tor da wir
setzen jetzt nein es geht in diesem fall
auch ganz knallhart nur ums geld massera
atmet einmal tief weil natürlich machst
du einen vertrag mit mit den den städten
und und dem stadien und dann tritt
dieses stade und diese stadt die rechte
ab sie hätten auch mal macht dieses
stadion
regenbogenfarben vom ersten tag an aber
reagiert nicht direkt und sagst es dann
auch noch das war ja auch noch
ungeschickt formuliert wir reagieren
jetzt damit auf das was in budapest im
parlament abgestimmt wurde und mit
mehrheit angenommen wurde ein war nicht
menschen nicht fertiges gesetz das ist
dass das gibt die vorlage für für
diejenigen die sagen pass auch bei uns
steht aber in den regularien das können
wir so nicht zu lassen und sie haben
dann in dem fall eine art hausrecht
ich versuche doch nur das ganze für so
nicht nicht nur mit mit mit der grossen
kelle sagen so jetzt die die die uefa
noch mal mit die uefa der europäer über
vieles kann man streiten aber sie machen
es sicher nicht weil sie plötzlich
homophob aber marcel hinein in einen in
einer gesunden und vernünftigen sport
bestimmt nicht hundertprozentig zu aber
das nicht dass überhaupt zu
thematisieren die binde von von von
manuel neuer oder dieses thema auch sie
könnten es sich so leicht machen einfach
positiv nach draußen etwas abzustrahlen
ich kann das nicht akzeptieren in einer
welt wo es ihnen egal ist ob eine
traumatisierte mannschaft wie bei
gottschalk gesagt hat weiter spielt
gegen finnland und dänemark von lehrer
habe ist jetzt die rede war von seinem
agenten genau wo eine traumatisierte
mannschaft einfach weiterspielen muss wo
es eben auch egal ist dass 60.000 leute
in ungarn ohne masken ohne abstände
stehen die ein riesen risiko für den
gesamten fußball anschließend und jetzt
nach deutschland gefahren ist wo es egal
ist ob man in ungarn fußball spielt wo
ein schadhaftes gesetz die botschaft ich
halt immer was ihr über geschafft hätten
wir probleme in butter welche botschaft
sendet denn dieses gesetz das das das
ist ja und mit dass sie anders sein
sollen dass sie nicht das gleiche recht
haben hier geht es um grundsätzliche
menschenrechte das ist eben alles egal
völlig unstrittig so gesehen alles egal
aber wir haben gesagt wir spielen bis
ich bin in einem land wie ungarn
wenn wir nur noch da spielen wo es
richtig in ordnung ist dann spielen wir
noch in der schweiz oder in
liechtenstein wirklich stolz sage ich
das ist dafür eigentlich ja nicht weißt
du dass das lasst uns die dinge wirklich
wissen also dass wir die ehe für alle
haben ist noch nicht so lange her dass
wir auch behindert worden sind weil sie
sagten die politiker dürfte doch sagen
der neue hat er trägt eine [ __ ]
binde
das sagt mir eine dieser dieses landes
der bevölkerung gewählt also insofern
mag nicht nur auf um dann ist das ja ich
habe den in budapest ich bin da gerne
und wenn du mit jungen menschen rede ist
das ist nicht das ganze land ist nicht
gesagt dass wir da nicht spielen sollen
ich habe ja nur gesagt wenn ich das
alles zieht ihre und diktaturen und und
despoten die veranstaltung gebe da ist
das ein wunderbares mittel mal als
sportorganisation auch mal zu sagen
jawohl
dann gehen wir machen wir jetzt mal
druck auf ihn war das ist eine schande
es ist eine schande was du da gemacht
hat und dann kriegt er eben ein bisschen
druck ja und aber nochmal auch wir haben
gebraucht für diese entwicklung und ich
sag mal so glauben unterstellt keinem
was wenn man sagt erst als eine klare
mehrheit von gut 60 prozent auch in
umfragen dafür war die ehe für alle
zuzulassen ging es dann plötzlich also
ich glaube wenn die mehrheit dagegen
gewesen wäre hätte noch im moment länger
gewartet der dfb habe papenburg welche
rolle spielt der erlebt zusammenhang
er hat das ja ähnlich wie macht er das
jetzt auch begründet hat hat er ja
gesagt so zu sagen wir können wir müssen
das gutheißen bzw
wir stimmen dem komplett zu weil es eben
eine politische entscheidung ist er hat
sich das halt in dieser form auch eben
sehr leicht gemacht und gesagt jetzt
rennsport und politik aneinander
zulässig für sie also ich sie wollen
zitiert präsidenten der bezieht sich
nicht auf diesen vorfall der bezieht
sich auf ganz andere vorgänge das ist
sozusagen
das ist jetzt tagesaktuell also das was
etwas was ich meinte mit dem anstand
bezieht sich auf einen ganz aktuellen
des dfb und der hat die ethikkommission
klären welche rolle spielt die waren für
die aufgelöst was sind die hintergründe
also die ethikkommission ist glaube ich
da sind wir uns alle einig ist eine
institution ist ein gremium und es steht
auch der dfb seite sie es absolut
unabhängig und sie arbeitet seitdem den
tod von thomas oppermann im vergangenen
oktober sozusagen nur mit vier nur noch
mit vier leuten und mit einem internet
chef thomas oppermann der spd-politik
genau der war ja eine vorsitzenden der
ethikkommission und nach seinem tod
irgendwann so plötzlichen tod ist er ist
dann der herr knobloch sozusagen
interims vorsitzender geworden dieser
ethikkommission die ethikkommission
behandelt ja alle fragen anfragen
jeglicher natur und gibt empfehlungen
bewertet das und gibt empfehlungen dann
in den meisten fällen weiter ans
sportgericht in diesem fall handelt es
sich um einen vorgang der aus unserer
initiative aus unserer fraueninitiative
fußball kein meer entstanden ist es geht
um die geschichte dass wir uns für
anfang des jahres mit einem
positionspapier sozusagen zu wort
gemeldet haben und da und der meinung
sind dass die zustände beim dfb auch
insbesondere nach dieser krise nicht
mehr haltbar sind und das ist ein
unbedingt ein neuanfang braucht und im
zuge dessen hat ist die also und eines
unserer mitglieder bibiana steinhaus die
schiedsrichterin sozusagen von rainer
koch unter druck gesetzt worden ob sie
sich tatsächlich dieser institution also
dieser der initiative anschließen möchte
und diese also auf diesem vorgang beruht
das ganze weil
also die gruppe und bei der ethik
kommission ein verfahren gegen rainer
koch wegen unter druck setzen den
emotionales unter druck unter druck
setzen eben daran an gespräche hat das
vieh hat das stattgefunden wie muss man
sich das vorstellen wie läuft so dass
wir haben das sozusagen wir haben das
sozusagen vor der von der eu vor die
ethikkommission gebracht unter druck
setzen wie lief das ab von sony ist
vorstellbar sofern es trotz es gibt
einen 1
es gibt mehrere bibiana sagt dazu immer
irritierende gespräche also 1 1 und 1
gipfelte darin dass und meiner koch sie
angerufen hat und einen sport redakteur
von der sport bild dazu geschaltet hat
ohne ihr ein ohne ihr ein also ohne
sehen ihr sich dafür zu informieren ohne
ihr überhaupt zu sagen dass da noch ein
weiterer mensch mit in der leitung ist
mit dem ziel dass er zu ihr gesagt hat
sie müssen jetzt sagen traunstein heißt
dass ich sie nicht unter druck gesetzt
aber also darauf bestanden dass sie dann
also erfolg vor den augen eines sport
mit redakteurs zudem bibiana nicht
wusste dass er mit den medialen ich
wusste dass er mit in der leitung ist
das war der hintergrund und bibiana ist
damit also wirklich um wenn man sie
kennt und ich glaube ihr könnt sie auch
alle ziemlich gut dann ist weiß man dass
sie in ein absolut integrer mensch ist
und dass sie jemand ist der überhaupt
nicht darauf aus ist jetzt auf krawall
revolution zu machen oder sonst
irgendwas und dass sie sich
hundertprozentig mit dem dfb auch
identifiziert und das ist ja genau das
problem
sie war dann sehr sehr also verunsichert
sehr aufgewühlt und wusste auch in
diesem fall nicht so richtig wie sie mit
dieser situation jetzt umgehen sollte
und ich muss dazu betonen dass nicht sie
sich weniger weil dies für die ethik
kommission gibt macht hat sondern wir
als gruppe weil wir gesagt haben es kann
nicht angehen dass jemand sie unter
druck setzt und sie sich nicht gegen
dagegen werden kann für ihn verlangen
der vorgang so etwas passiert und dieses
hat dann zu einem zu einem verfahren
geführt und dieses verfahren wurde gegen
rainer koch sozusagen jetzt geführt von
herrn knobloch und der amtierenden
ethikkommission und aus unerfindlichen
gründen wurde auf einmal auf die auf die
sitzung auf die präsidiumssitzung das
thema gehoben dass er über den vorsitz
der ethikkommission gesprochen werden
muss und dass der ein neuer interessent
zu sagen dass ein neuer chef bestimmt
werden muss was eigentlich ursprünglich
erst für den nächsten bundestag
vorgesehen war und das landete dann ganz
plötzlich also überfallartig sozusagen
auf der präsidiumssitzung und dort wurde
abgestimmt und es wurde stimmung gemacht
gegen herrn knobloch mit angeblichen
verfahren die gegen indem es wurde
definitiv stimmung gemacht mit
falschinformationen auch zu den allzu
dem anderen ethik kommissionsmitglied
und das führt am ende dazu dass eine das
eine eine dame aus dieser
ethikkommission ihren akku macht dann zu
neuen vorsitzenden bestimmt wurde sich
sozusagen in der abstimmung ging gegen
knobloch durchsetzte und die anderen die
restlichen drei mitglieder dann
geschlossen zurückgetreten sind dh die
ethikkommission existiert gerade nicht
hat sich sozusagen gesprengt und damit
ist auch das verfahren wahrscheinlich
jetzt in dieser frage nicht wird jetzt
nicht weiter angestrengt was ich meine
mit anstand ist einfach die geschichte
wenn man dann weiß dass in dieser
präsidiumssitzung rainer koch selber mit
abgestimmt hat dann meine ich das mit
anstand meine ich wenn ich bin ich teil
eines verfahrens bin und solche vorwürfe
gegen mich erhoben werden dann verstehe
ich mich ehrlich gesagt
es versteht sich von selbst dass ich
dann nicht wenigstens der stimme
enthalten
innerhalb dieses verfahrens dass sie
jetzt lebt präsidium entscheidet über
den vorsitz oder über die gesamte
zusammensetzung einer ethikkommission
die manchmal deren fantasie gerade sagte
dies unabhängig
die sollen abhängig in der satzung
sozusagen oder marcel reif wäre projekt
ist rainer koch eigentlich bundestag
eine woche ist das element der seit
langer langer zeit einen ganz wichtigen
positionen sind lange vize und er
überlebt sie alle
ein phänomen belebt alle präsidenten und
sisi purzeln ja im zweijahresrhythmus
sowie ja so wie herr keller keine ahnung
glätte bei der letzte einer koch steht
eisern und fest und überlebt sie alle
dass ich bin bin ich kann mir nicht
dicht jetzt erlauben zu sagen da und da
das was du mir das ja und da hat er
fallen gespielt aber das ist schon
faszinierend wie wie jemand aus all
diesen dingen immer als und immer heißt
es er ist ein strippenzieher ist ein
strippenzieher ist ein strick bisher
aber noch mal ich will nicht irgendwas
behaupten was ich nicht nicht beweisen
kann nur was was auffällt ist und alle
gehen er hat und was auffällt ist da
geht es offensichtlich dass verstehe
sogar ich so von außen da geht es um
macht und wie vielen verschiedenen
positionen um das mal ganz kurz runter
zu brechen ist herr koch eigentlich
tätig also er ist interes vorsitzende
des dfb- präsidiums also stwb im moment
in dfb-präsident sozusagen interims
präsident der free präsident er ist
vorsitzende des bayerischen
landesverbandes er ist vorsitzender des
wegen des darüber stehen denn
regionalverbandes ich glaube das ist
regionalverband süd er ist es in der
uefa-exekutive kommission
das ist schon das dritte amt und dann
hat dfb landesverband regionalverband
ist es hat vier dafür stimmte dass die
stimme aus dem uefa exekutivkomitee
nicht aber in allen präsidial
entscheidungen an dem die landesverbände
und die regionalverbände beteiligt sind
hat er jeweils seine drei stimmen und
die drei stimmen kann er einsetzen
ist das der grund warum marcel reif sagt
was ich beim dfb abspielt ist jämmerlich
nur deswegen nur das baden an koch fest
machen wäre wäre nicht okay was muss ich
also fairerweise sagen nicht größeren
aber was noch
immerhin zeit und wirklich keiner zeit
die kinder können nicht mehr fußball
spielen der fußball für die die stadt
jugendfußball befindet sich seit
amateurfußball die baby haben uns daran
gewöhnt dass die profis den leeren
stadien gespielt haben wenigstens
spielen konnten aber all das andere
passiert nicht sich darum zu kümmern
wäre doch eine eine heilige aufgabe
gewesen aber so ziehen die sich im
vorjahr die kommission generalsekretär
um sie dann selber die beamten die sich
dann schaffe ich dann wieder sie selber
explodiert das ist nicht einfach nur
dass die außendarstellung ich habe auch
keine lust mich mit denen ich bin kein
verbandsfunktionäre und auch keinen
fachmann in diesen dingen
ich hätte nur gerne dass der direkte
grüner dass der größte sportfachverband
der welt ein anderes bild nach außen
abgibt als über die letzten vier
jahrzehnte am stück am stück du denkst
immer sommer
das sieht das ist doch das ist so wie im
sandkasten könnten nicht ständig mit
murmeln und mit sand werfen aufeinander
gibt es nicht irgendwas zu tun in diesem
verband außer sich selber überflüssig zu
machen auf diese art braucht diesen cup
aktiv das nicht tust den db und es gibt
viele menschen die im kleinen in den bg
opfer auf der auf dem land viele viele
dinge viele gute dinge machen auch im
dfb aber die haben eine bessere führung
verdient als die die die diesen verband
seit führungen diese diesen verband bei
unseren der film und da sind wir beim
thema und du sagst du hast keine lust da
irgendwie sich mit dieser thematik zu
beschäftigen aber wir haben ja lust hat
zu viele jeden fall dass ich selber
abstimmt kann es nicht sein dass er mit
mehreren stimmen abstimmen kann was ist
geht bei mir jedes recht verstehen also
wir reden hier über ämterhäufung wir
reden über amtszeit begrenzungen wir
reden über all diese ganzen dinge die
dringend notwendig sind damit nämlich
genauso einfach mal sache aber in ja und
in die zukunft gehen kann damit der
zukunftsfähig ist denn du hast da gebe
ich dir völlig recht wenn das so
weitergeht wie bisher dann hat sich
dieser verband in relativ kurzer zeit
überholt